وقبر خالد في حمص
نلامسه
فيرجف القبر من زواره غضبا يا رب حيا رخام
القبر مسكنه ورب ميتا على اقدامهم قصدا يا
ابن الوليد الا سيف تؤجره فكل اسيافنا قد
اصبحت خشن
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
والشعب ماذا سيبقى من اصالته اذا تولاه
نصاب ومداح وكيف نكتب والاقفال في فمنا
وكل ثانيه
ياتيك سفاح
[موسيقى]
وهل المراه شيء اخر غير الوطن اه لو يدرك
من يقراوني انما اكتبه في الحب مكتوب
لتحرير الوطن يعني بعتبر انا ان الوطن هل
للمراه فيه عبده هو وطن مستعمر
[موسيقى]
اصبح عند الان
بندقيه الى فلسطين
خذوني معكم الى ربا حزينه
كوجه مج
دا الى القباب الخطف
والحجاره النبي
[موسيقى]
بلقيس كيف
ذهبت صامته ولم تضع يديك على يدي
كيف تركتنا في الريح
نرجف مثل اوراق الشجر
اتراك ما فكرت بيه وانا الذي
يحتاج حبك مثل زينب او عمر
[موسيقى]
فالحب عليك هو المكتوب انا اقدم عاصمه
للحزن
وانجرحي نقش الفراق
عيناك وبغ
منذ طفوله
شمساني نايمه تاني في عذابي
[موسيقى]
يا امي يا امي انا الولد الذي ابحر ولا
زالت بخاطره تعيش عروسه السكر
فكيف فكيف يا امي غدوت ابا ولم